today on versus it's a gargantuan gotham
grudge match that will see the greatest
batman villains take on each other in a
winner take all event designed to once
and for all proclaim the mightiest dark
knight foe ever that's dark knight is in
the character not the movie because then
it would obviously be joker right yeah
oh no wait two faces in there too hmm
qualifying for today's fearsome foil
fragrance will be big screen baddies
such as the riddler penguin catwoman
scarecrow bane two face and the purveyor
of everyone's favorite pencil gag joker
it's
gone there's a chance a few other evil
doers could sneak into contextion al
gold family picnic i'm looking at you
but as of now those are your odds on
favorite to win today's contest of
course the real winner here today is
batman because he gets to take a break
from chasing these nerdy wells all
around town it's miller time bruce so
how's about you and alfred kick back
relax and maybe book a therapy session
as for this battle here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three dastardly deeds round
four cultural legacy and then we'll do a
wild card round that given the twisted
nature of these foes could involve
anything from gadgets to costume to
backstory uh you only get one of those
jokers so pick a lane
and friendly reminder that i your
justice defending host mark ellis will
only be making my decisions based on
your big screen accomplishments i will
leave the door open for both live action
and animated adventures i'll also demand
that you have significant screen time in
those movies so don't hold your breath
clayface what are you doing
stop it all right the stage is set the
contenders are most likely laughing
maniacally and i'm standing atop the
tallest building in the city hopefully
with a bungee cord because i am afraid
of heights let's get it on and
here we
go round one box office
and let's just get this out of the way
right now as rabid fans of this show
will tell you anytime i get a chance to
remind folks about the summer of 1989
i'm gonna do it it was the season that
introduced me to movie theater nachos
converse chuck taylors and block busting
lines wrapped around the well block all
because of a movie called batman for the
very first time i started to wrap my
tiny brain around the fact that a movie
about a famous superhero just might be a
good way to make a buck and in a round
titled box office it's all about who
made the most cheddar and now i'm hungry
for nachos again you want to get nuts
come on sure batman himself is a huge
draw but sometimes it's the villains who
make us leave the friendly confines of
our couch and join the season of
humanity heading to a local cathedral of
cinema because you just can't wait for
this one to hit the shelves in your
local video store such was the case in
89 and even though we now regard michael
keaton as arguably the greatest caped
crusader of them all
back then he was a name jack nicholson
was a star no petitions were robbed
jack's way when it was announced that he
would be taking over his joker filling
the clown shoes originated on celluloid
by the legendary caesar romero batman
1989 would go on to haul in 590 million
dollars in the united states alone when
we adjust for inflation look in 1989 you
could get a gallon of gas for like three
pennies and a smile now it's seven
dollars which kind of feels like a scam
drummed up by a batman villain but i
digress another word
joker would take a seat on the
live-action bench until 2008 when he
returned courtesy of heath ledger who
played him to the tune of 698 million
dollars jared leto's version added a few
more hundred mil into the vault and
joaquin phoenix's actual clown raked in
335 million dollars domestically that
joker film also hauled in a billion
bucks worldwide which makes it the
highest grossing flick featuring that
lunatic ever
i'll also give props to zach
galifianakis lego batman joker which
earned 186 million dollars here in the
states additionally mask of the phantasm
and the 1966 batman had great joker
portrayals thanks to mark hamill and
caesar romero but we don't have reliable
box office data for those so the door
may be open especially when it comes to
another recurring favorite thorn and
batman side catwoman meow michelle
pfeiffer took over for wee merryweather
eartha kitt and julie newmar for 1992's
batman returns and that sequel grossed
368 million dollars just one mil short
of zoe kravitz's feline princess in the
batman anne hathaway suited up for the
dark knight rises which made off with
598 million dollars and howie berry who
was fresh off in oscar win at the time
donned the tights for the film catwoman
which licked up 59 million dollars total
the recurring theme in this round is
that it helps to have multiple
performers play you over a number of
decades to pile on that box office might
riddler would be in that category as
batman forever generated 396 million
dollars thanks to no small part to jim
carrey's participation as well as the
buffoonery hating tommy lee jones's
two-face
batman and robin's box office inflates
to 219 million dollars in today money
thanks to the pumping up of arnold's mr
freeze and uma thurman's poison ivy hey
bane is in that one too
the backbreaker also menaces in the dark
knight rises and the lego batman movie
hi doug benson hello
we even have some surprise entries
competing for a point in this round make
some noise for
carmine falcone or falcone tom wilkinson
and john turturro have played the
mobster and batman begins and the batman
respectively so that amounts to a
worldwide take of over a billion dollars
which buys a lot of cd nightclubs
scarecrow was wise to show up in the
dark knight rises a film that did over a
billion bucks alone and then we'll toss
in batman begins his 359 million total
as well and wait what's that good god
that's lex luthor's music boy do we have
problems up here he's in batman v
superman but come on you can't count
supes as a villain in that film bvs
hauled in 872 million dollars and we
really should be thanking lex for
setting up that pay-per-view battle in
the first place lots of dollars being
generated by tons of celebrity baddies
but it all comes down to the law of
averages catwoman purrs hard here
notching over 1.3 domesticated billion
making for a per film average of 334
million can anyone top that he asked
with a question mark the riddler can hey
guys
yeah he's got a 382 million dollar per
movie average on his scorecard and omg i
forgot about the penguin
danny devito colin farrell and purchase
mayor of the team up to forge a 1.2
billion dollar total take and that
accounts for over 400 million dollars on
average which topples even the joker who
has a 391 million dollar average if only
they let mask of the phantasm have an
extended theatrical run so in what looks
like a surprise win here it's the
monogamous winged freak who can't fly is
he really gonna take this wait a minute
what's that it's another twist someone
has an even higher average than the
pittsburgh hockey team it's not bane who
does boast a respectable 379 million
dollar per film average it's two-face
you live
you die
now we're talking aaron eckhart and the
guy that thought harrison ford killed
his wife combined for a role that's
quite literally grossed over a billion
dollars which is two movies which makes
a perfect average of 547 million dollars
that blows away the competition so hard
i don't even have to flip a coin to see
who wins in this round and even though
billy d williams wasn't a bad guy 1989
batman he did play mayor harv so i'm
giving bonus points the only point that
really matters here of course is the
round one gold and it goes to two face
heads for him tails for everyone else
and it's one to nothing dent gets on the
board first
round two tomato meter slash audience
score the good news for two-face is that
the box office doesn't really care how
good your movie is just how many people
thought it might be worth paying to see
but here in round two a premium will be
placed on how many faces had smiles on
them as they exited the theater and that
might spell doom for the man with two
faces because the dark knight is hailed
as a classic and batman forever is
considered a movie
it has its supporters for sure and i'm
all for batman eating more fast food but
according to the tomato meter it's a 39
rotten movie rebounded by the dark
knights 94 somehow the audience scores
even lower for tommy lee jones's lone
entry in the batman canon it falls at 32
while the dark knight holds strong once
again showing a 94 bane's gonna have an
even tougher time with these two eras of
superhero
super villain movies because batman and
robin yeah it's a 12
on the tm and only improves to 16 with
the audience score the dark knight rises
heals this wound considerably as it
contributes an 87 critic score and a 90
from us normies but the penguin he's
been fresh in every decade he's appeared
even though i'm not sure penguins like
that kind of water
[Applause]
a combined tv and movie score for the
1960s era of batman gives penguin a 79
percent on the tomato meter and it only
goes up from there batman returns is it
80 and the batman is 85 percent adding
up to a 83 average in the tomato patch
the audience agrees as that metric
awards penguin 82 per outing that best
banes 49 average and two faces 66 easily
but the film catwoman does hold the
dubious honor of being the low bar for
all movies we're talking about today as
far as the tomato meter is concerned
nine percent
i'm fine
i am fine a film that only gets one
percent for every one of ferris
bueller's absences or cat lives that's a
tough hill to climb but the dark knight
rises as we know is 87 percent and she's
got two other outings in the 80 range
somehow catwoman is able to claw herself
to a fresh average on both measurements
with a 68 tomato meter average and a 66
audience score so catwoman two face and
band are all chilling backstage waiting
for round three to start let's be honest
shut up meanwhile here it's up to either
riddler or joker to take down the
wodliest villain that ever did waddle
riddler could have done it but he was in
batman forever and that 39 is going to
send him packing
he still gets to fresh for averages
though 67 percent on the tomato meter 60
for the audience so now it all comes
down to the joker vs penguin matchup and
i would pay top dollar to have morgan
freeman announce this good luck joker
has an ace on the whole as he's the solo
evil doer of note in 1989's batman with
all apologies to bob who is a very loyal
and now very dead first mate but
curiously that film is only 73
on the tomato meter which is wrong
luckily there's a podcast for that the
audience was more accurate because they
gave it an 84
will it be enough well it could have
been in fact the joker averages
virtually near that of the penguins but
breaking the tie it's a little oscar
winner called suicide squad
okay so the audience score for that 2016
flick is 58 so you're still in this joke
heads but not anymore because the tomato
meter rests at a still better than
catwoman 12
taking the best lap this side of woody
woodpecker down to a 73 tomato meter
average which means the penguin wins
round two
like fellow sewer dwellers pennywise in
the ninja turtles the penguin gets a win
and ties two-face at one-to-one
meanwhile every other batman baddie is
still hoping to get on the board
[Music]
round three dastardly deeds
and now we get to have some fun albeit
at the expense of many gotham innocents
but let's be honest when batman is
patrolling the town it all works out at
the end of the day right now sure you
may get a few cuts bruises poison water
flooding tainted beauty products great
great weather but we all survived right
batman's still here alfred is still
butlering rachel is still
oh
right yeah sometimes those dastardly
deeds the name doesn't sound menacing
enough for what actually transpires
particularly when it comes to bane i
don't know if the dude even watched the
1960s batman villains ham it up but he
was not interested in having a good time
while teasing superheroes he's looking
for all-out entropy on a scale which
even gotham had never witnessed inspired
by the algol family bane forced an
island habitat upon bruce wayne's
hometown destroying all the bridges that
could safely get one out of gotham and
to top it off he also blew up the
football stadium just after kickoff so i
guess he's more of a baltimore ravens
fan of course bane's methodology may be
more cutthroat but he still showed off a
flare for the dramatic that echoes the
greats that came before him caesar
romero's joker lived up to the namesake
as everything he did was cheeky and came
with a laugh he even sprung himself from
prison one time using a wait for it
giant spring sprung
you can say that again all the silly
antics add up to romero getting a pass
for refusing to shave his mustache for
the part jack nicholson's jack napier
became the joker after a double cross
resulted in him being dumped into a vat
of axis chemicals as would become
typical with joker's plans he was never
really looking to accomplish anything
other than chaos in 1989 batman that
means creating a wave of smilex products
that unbeknownst to gotham's denizens
will make their face contort into a wide
grin just before they perish love that
joker
he didn't care if the products made him
rich he just wanted to stick it to the
batman heath ledger's joker robbed a
bank and still didn't care about the
money as michael kane's alfred put it so
eloquently some men
just want to watch the world burn ledger
and mark hamill's portrayals are linked
in their realization that as much fun as
it is to torture and confound batman
they need him to be who he is because
otherwise what's the point you complete
me catwoman on the other hand she looks
at batman with a bemused disposition not
unlike how cats treat their humans 95 of
the time romantic entanglements may or
may not come up but catwoman is looking
out for number one and doesn't really
care about destroying gotham unless it
gets in her way michelle pfeiffer's
version is pretty po that max schreck
pushed her out a window and hathaway's
take was looking to clear her name after
a life of cat burglary seemed to really
hurt her credit score sometimes catwoman
can even seem like a feline heroine zoe
kravitz's goal was to take down a very
bad father figure in carmine and she
even ended up saving batman's life and
i'll say this again she had the cooler
motorcycle scooter thing way cooler but
in that same movie paul dano's riddler
is doing some truly nefarious stuff
[Music]
you know like murdering prominent
politicians and leaving bird-based clues
in their wake although i must point out
he's doing this because there's a ton of
corruption within the highest halls of
gotham's elite so maybe he did us a
favor
how can you say that jim carrey's
riddler definitely didn't in fact
remember his goal it was to make us all
drooling zombies to the point where
lloyd christmas would be the smartest
guy in town
edward enigma had invented a brainwave
technology for wayne enterprises what
began as a virtual reality experiment
became a twisted way for riddler to
steal all of the city's intelligence for
himself tommy lee jones wants a
comeuppance for bats because he didn't
stop the acid from ruining the hot shot
lawyer's face when it was tossed at him
aaron eckhart teams up with joker in the
dark knight as a means to gain revenge
on all those who wronged him but if it's
revenge-a-like everyone else has taken a
backseat to oswald cobblepot
huh
danny devito's penguin was abandoned by
his parents so he initially wants blood
that being the firstborn of every fancy
gothamite oh and while we're doing so
let's also become the mayor and then
will be untouchable meanwhile colin
farrell's penguin is a mobster with
plenty of vendettas and for some reason
the actor agreed to get that makeup done
time and time again for an upcoming
streaming show that i will definitely be
watching boy hear everything they say
oh the classic batman villains teamed up
for a fun dastardly deed in the 1960s
they dehydrated the town reducing the
united world organization security
council to a pile of dust which is what
you get for naming your global club you
wish
and i thought my jokes were bad batman
and robin did eventually rehydrate them
but some of those council members would
never be the same so when it all comes
down to it each one of these villains
has a clear goal in mind and thus a plot
is hatched but as a wisened pennyworth
intimated the scariest force on earth is
one that doesn't have an end game it's
one that simply enjoys the ride so much
so that they put their head out the
window while driving a stolen cop car
just to feel the breeze it's the joker
that finally gets on the board in this
match winning round three and tying the
lead at one point a piece
round four cultural legacy much to
batman chagrin each one of his primary
foes have been able to transcend the
role of mere villain and become icons of
pop culture in their own right so much
so that a few of them have been able to
get their own movie or series green lit
how does that work exactly you killed a
bunch of people cost the city billions
of dollars in damages no one sure will
ever go near gotham again but you you're
a star kid do that little penguin thing
again joker might be the most obvious
choice if you're picking favorites here
dude has had the best actors of multiple
generations begging to play him and now
joaquin phoenix who is so compelling in
the standalone joker story that the
movie made over a billion at the box
office and has a sequel in development
joker's legacy extends beyond opening
weekend numbers however thanks primarily
to heath ledger and his posthumous
awards season prowess although the actor
passed away tragically before the dark
knight was released his take was honored
with oscar gold at the academy awards
this opened the floodgates for a-listers
looking for meaty parts to keep their
star shining and their pocketbooks full
and while we may not see a main movie
any time soon talking like bane still
immediately conjures images of the
carnage he brought to town and the dark
knight rises oh yes the voice and
intonation has been parodied in
countless stand-up routines snl sketches
and big time comedies like were the
millers
can you name any film character outside
of borat that has been more imitated
this century ooh that's a fun versus
idea napoleon dynamite get ready
it may have been tough to decipher what
the hell bane was saying but it did pack
a punch he gets additional points for
being known as the guy that broke
batman's back it was a dark time when
the comic came out in the 90s kids you
had bane taking out bruce's spinal cord
doomsday killed superman and i had to
take a break from comic books thanks for
being there for me magic the gathering
penguin and riddler have a shared
history of being mount rushmore
contenders simply because of their
staying and star power dana devito and
colin farrell are household names and
burgess meredith would go on to play
rocky's legendary trainer mick and the
hilarious dad in grumpy old men what's
he have for breakfast i eat five strips
of bacon
riddler was such a juicy part that paul
dano not known for seeking the limelight
with his roles jumped at the chance and
jim carrey was the hottest comedy star
in the universe when he donned the
questionable spandex batman forever was
released in the summer of 1995. the
previous year he burst on the scene with
all timers like aceventura the mask and
dumb and dumber which makes me wonder
you know jeff daniels would have been an
interesting two-face i'm just saying
for me catwoman is the biggest rival to
joker in this round and whereas joker's
legacy is shared with the actress who
played him the role of catwoman herself
has cemented a unique place in comic
book and film war she could be whoever
she wants to be on any given day like us
real people she's just figuring it out
as she goes along and like most cats her
mood dictates her actions so one day
she's blown up a storefront the next
she's actually doing society a favor and
dating all the way back to the 1960s
whether is julie newmar or eartha kid on
the small screen or we merryweather on
the big one this was a villain who could
hang with the boys when it came to
schemes barbs and badassery in what
still feels like a male-dominated genre
characters like catwoman are much more
than just a cool villain or hero or
anti-hero it's a symbol of female
empowerment and independence joker may
have more awards on his mantle as of now
but catwoman stands tallest amongst her
peers when it comes to being a singular
force in the culture and advancement of
entertainment the kitty with the claws
gets the win in this round and it's all
knotted up like attempting ball of yarn
at one point a piece
and now it's time for the wild card
round the wet bandits it all comes down
to this two-faced penguin joker and
catwoman have all won a round thus far
so they steal another point they'll be
declared the winner if not it'll be a
five-way tie at the top and i'll have to
make the pick now the dear viewer out
there may be wondering what is this
round all about who has the edge well
you remember the wet bandits from home
alone yeah they weren't criminal
masterminds but they had enough combined
brain cells to know that every great
baddie has a calling card for them it
was leaving the sinks running and
flooding their victims homes man
villains really love wasting water
what's wrong with you why do you do that
i told you not to do it thus the wild
card point will go to the villain who
has the most distinct signature move the
calling card that lets all of gotham
know which criminal megamind is behind a
particular dastardly deed for joker he
takes the idea of calling card quite
literally rare isn't that he's not
playing with a deck of cards and most
evenings in gotham you're bound to find
a joker card near the scene of a crime
for jack napier the lucky deck wasn't
necessarily all that fortunate it was
the swindler crime boss grissom who
reminded jack to take his cards with
them on a robbery that turned out to be
a double cross of course that was right
after jack palance's character reminded
nicholson that you
are my number one guy
setting the tone for comic book film
finales to follow batman begins gives us
a sequel opportunity when during the
denu ma which is book speak for
aftermath jim gordon and batman
commiserate about how the city is safe
but for how long it's then that gordo
ooh can i please call him that i
wouldn't know that
shows him the joker card in the evidence
ziploc indicating that there's a new
sinister force on the streets we'll have
to deal with you know if this first
movie is successful it was we got the
next chapter and it turned out to be an
all-timer most folks go to vegas to play
cards and win them some coin which is
where two-face comes in nary is a
decision made until he flips his lucky
monetary note and allows fate to have
the final say in a weird twist of that
fate it was a 50 50 coin flip that
batman was racing to the right location
to rescue his beloved rachel in the dark
knight ah it turns out she was across
town so instead we got to save harvey
dent but this is not going to be the
tent that we know not anymore and in
batman forever it's two-face who takes
particular glee and the unknown future
the coin holds in classic bond villain
style that ended up being his downfall
as batman brought a whole laundromat
full of change with him to the climactic
battle i'm not gonna penalize bane too
hard for not having a calling card
because i value my spine in its current
alignment i will break you and catwoman
may occasionally leave a scratch or a
claw mark possibly even a nail but
that's about it now i will say if you
happen to be in the company of a young
lady at her place and she has a neon
sign that says hell here uh she's got a
busy nightlife to contend with actually
maybe catwoman's best signature is
what's not there if something is missing
at your residence don't blame the maid
it's likely in the paws of selena kyle
oops
penguin brings his purple suit and
animal kingdom buddies to most parties
as his top hat is as recognizable to him
as it gets meanwhile riddler hey guys
may be the last candidate to have a real
shot here because that question mark
shows up in the darndest of spots at the
most inconvenient of times maybe it's a
simple cafe latte or a gruesome crime
scene but it can also show up as the new
bat signal itself say what you want
about batman forever but that question
mark logo is almost as cool as the
bleeding superman s on that iconic comic
book cover i told you all the 90s were
dark for heroes luckily we had mr
freeze's trademark puns to lighten the
mood let's
take some ice when it all comes down to
it joker has become so legendary that
he's even more popular than his playing
card inspiration riddler has his logo
game on fleek do the kids still say that
no
and two-face has the ultimate torture
device with his coin flip but the fact
that joker once called himself that just
to mess with the backstabbing crying
boss that done him wrong is just too
delicious to pass up joker gets the
point takes the round and thus wins the
match
what an effort by all of our truly evil
except sometimes you catwoman band of
batman baddies so keep in mind the joker
winning today is just my opinion and
i've never once watched any tights hit
me up on social media with your take at
mark ellis live for upcoming tour dates
including my new hour special taping in
la that's in december go to mark ellis
dot live for all the latest when it
comes to batman and his cronies keep it
right here at rotten tomatoes thanks for
watching this edition of versus i'm your
host mark ellis and i think i'm gonna
give myself a bath right here
[Applause]
you